okay let's go
I'm just going around my students houses
detect little jet but you really have
that care for you tenants I can see and
she's making twelve hundred pound profit
I'm uh I'm gonna be running the very
first crash course outside of England to
let an agent still gonna hassle you
having emotional flashbacks ran fast and
don't stop the deal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for basically his situation so Stella
she having windows Wednesday you saw the
video right yeah little bit
so to summarize her story she came to
the crash course she came to the
classical she only had 9,000 pound in a
bank and that 9,000 pounds that she had
in a bank she was planning on using it
to will find a house however I told her
to not buy a house I told her to use
that money to join the Academy now
obviously for me I was taking a risk
because then if they don't do anything
with the Academy then they can say oh
man now I'm left with nothing but all I
believe if you're gonna take action
getting the knowledge is just ye better
investing in yourself they're putting
nine run into what some little tiny
pokey houses can give you a hundred and
fifty pounds off for a month so I talked
to the Academy she's now in the Academy
with no money okay and she owes a little
bit of money towards the academies there
so she's now in debt and she's got a
full-time job so now we got this girl
she's done the Academy she's got nothing
she's actually in debt now and what does
she do she goes on the rent of rent
revolution she finds some rental rents
however she's got no money
she takes out a 20,000 pound personal
loan and puts it into rent to rent put
into one mentor man
she's risky as ever and I don't know I
would've probably said don't do it
however that rent event has turned out
really good
apparently she said she's making how
much on that woman to rent I think it's
like a grand yeah or more to grand
and then she's used the savings to get
another enter in another word to it
she's now financially free she's now
making four thousand pound approximate
life of memory now the thing is I hear
these stories all the time on windows
Wednesday every time someone comes on
windows means that I have to sign
something just how everything's true but
this story I'm just like how can you
make so much profit on moments around
its if it have a peculiar story so I
just figured I'd go down meet her and I
want to actually look at her portfolio I
want to see our renter answer to see
that there really are its profitable
because maybe she got lucky maybe she's
gonna look into three four five months
and I just want to check out the that
they're good have a look at them I'll
write them and it'd be nice to see
Stella so that is this bad situation
yeah before those yeah but when you once
important when you're quite it oh yes
already my all of this they've got six
of me hm
okay because I've been told I need to
write each each province a six of them
on sweetie wow this is a proper HMS this
is a not messing about right next to the
hospital
walk really close I'm really going to
this centre of Oxford okay this room you
got literally before you even join the
account yes and you've been on the
academy now about five months it's
exactly yeah so okay wow that's great
well it's good to see a year is it good
because now you can see exactly over a
year how much profit you made yeah
and how much have you made over the year
than in total profit in profit of me
I'll be about fourteen fourteen crossing
Grantham this year really good so talk
about twelve in Japan a month profits
strong good
[Music]
that's good yeah so every room has got a
female in it yes does that deliver it
yeah
so I just saw it as it would just be
better for them to major age as well how
old good so all women bar one man who
lives in one of the rooms all similar
age range they're all working that's why
you've got a great day a great house
there that's why I'm really impressed
I'm not gonna lie I mean this is like
the perfect rent to rent you brought a
lot of money up front this is nice
so did you furnish the room yes I'm so
confused
okay yeah yeah good interested in
between yeah in terms of rent like how
much this one is eight twenty eight
twenty and then what about the one that
we just saw downstairs
790 790 what's the cheapest rent she was
one I have this one less than one
ensuite and that is six six five so the
cheapest is 6 6 5 and then this is the
most expensive today what supplier you
with we are bills for the bills good
good I usually do the best but all my
properties you have a friend who's a
distributor hi Daddy
okay she was what I do is I have
a friend who's a YouTube's disappear
yeah and I don't get Commission every
time I get have it's actually no but
then that scores me like it's good well
and then every now and then they'll pass
me a property deal hmm which will make
me like 50 grand you have to put down 20
grand for this deal but it's worth there
people can't even people can't even say
oh yeah and that's what you need to do
sometimes sometimes in business this is
what people don't say you know you used
to start with nothing people think a
stove nothing I've got nothing to lose
we have because you've got 20 grand
personal loan against your name to lose
you know just cuz you've got nothing
doesn't even nothing to lose having
nothing to good place for some people
some people are so wrapped up in debt
and and responsibilities and problems
they'd love to be fresh start
but great job water so I think Samuel is
going to give it a 7 because there is a
good location and there are six ensuite
rooms which he looks really excited
about
I think the down part is the bet he did
say it's a small dog wall so I don't
think he really liked the whole bed
situation something that might be where
he nuts about that was a really good
property that was it was just everything
was just working so wow I'm really
impressed
what am I gonna write it out of 10 the
only thing as I said the only thing that
could have been better is that she could
have put less money down upfront but I
managed to put down upfront it was only
up front rent so it's not like it's lost
so actually that property I'm an oven
about that town 10 10 out of 10
great tenants great property great
location great rooms all female rooms
which is nice
she's on top of it it's clean and she's
making 1200 pound profit a month 1200
pound prof. him up and it was a normally
done deal because she used a bank loan
to get the property anyway so Tara 10 10
out of 10
I'm gonna be running the very first
crash course outside of England in
Edinburgh this week property - investors
code at UK get to Edinburgh it's gonna
be magical man you won't regret it rent
around number two i rated number one the
first mortgage I rate that four out of
ten so let's see what I rate that for so
as to see if we can get any higher than
a four if you live in London and you
have these houses in Oxford how do you
manage like every day running of the
properties yeah could you have a
full-time job so you live in like an
hour on 19 minutes away
depending on traffic it could be more
you have a full-time job you've got all
properties you've got how many tenants
until it's 32 tenants like that's a lot
man how much time would you say on
average you spend like managing the
whole portfolio a week okay and family
or how often do you visit Oxford yeah
what day do you come yeah yes are you
tying today with anything practical are
you tying today and with anything
practical or
what time that well listen you you you
just booked it if you want and then
we'll make sure we're there so before we
go in how much are you paying the
landlord for this house two thousand two
hundred and how much are you getting in
renting total on this one how much he
making 920 brilliant
no ice was in the kitchen already here
yes how long did this property take to
fill it from scratch um a month okay
took me a month to get five tenants then
I why would this landlord why would he
not just pay a letting agent why would
he let you have nine hundred twenty
pound a month profit every month from
this house and not just pay an agent and
get the money himself so basically even
when you've got a lane engine the land
agents still gonna hassle you and say oh
there's no telling this and oh and just
call you or say oh the door handles
broken do you want me to fix it so from
his perspective he's just like keep the
money possibly yes some people you know
want the least the least hassle because
time ultimately is money but then from
your perspective you spend a few hours a
week doing it but then you're happy to
do that
yeah well probably I might be going you
tell me like in ten years do you want to
be doing regiments right you want to use
the money you make from it to rent to
build your own portfolio so this is
almost like the step the stepping stone
again yeah right by refurbish refinance
and I bet as well you've learned a ton
about property from actually doing this
[Music]
yeah yeah love it you really have that
care for you tenants I can see and also
it's better for me as marketing they're
not happy with me yeah so I mean in the
long running it pays off to make sure
you how do you reference your tenant
what do watch XD de and so I use
experience
[Music]
so the experience and that was sauce
third-party company that do all the
checks how much you pay them to do all
that there's not a lot and do you take
deposits how five weeks deposit and you
register that do you register yourself
where do you do that my deposits that
code it you go fantastic great good you
definitely know what you're doing do you
know what it's so funny cuz this smell
reminds me so much of the first few
years of me being in property of a nice
to come out and furnish the rooms and I
can it's almost talk about new flat-pack
smell did you get the furniture then I'm
going to put this in I can just smell
that new flat-pack smell and it reminds
me of being on my hands and knees with a
screwdriver and bits and their little
plastic little see-through bags in bits
like would you con washes and stuff cuz
I used to do it all myself I used to
just flat back everything everything I
stood on myself but now I can't say I've
smelt that smell in years so it's it's
really quite about I'm having emotional
flashbacks yeah really really nice like
yeah how long have you lived here okay
and what is Stella like as a landlord
yeah
don't be embarrassed contact for
anything that's good it can be really
really stupid I can be serious hey
thanks so much to me John sorry to
trouble you on your day off as well all
right enjoy
thanks so much bye thank you so much I
think the thing I'm really impressed
with is Estella to be honest the house
is a great but without good tenants
there wouldn't be great the only reason
we're saying the deals good is because
the tenants are good but that comes
because of Stella's rapport because of
her willingness to Skype the tenants and
I'm impressed so I personally would rate
this property innate because it's got
good finishings the landlord put
everything in for me so I didn't have to
buy any furniture and it's a good
location good tenants and bathroom to
tenancies ratio is really good as well
and I believe Samuel would rate this an
8 as well because I didn't have to put
down a large upfront lettuce and Randall
provided order furniture so this
property the Landlord only wanted one
month's rent upfront one month's deposit
he paid for everything else so the
furniture the landlord paid for the
profit on this
Stella's making 920 pound a month profit
and it's all filled we've been in there
I even bumped into one of the tenants
upstairs and it's just so tidy and so
nice inside great location I know this
is really cheesy but I can't give it any
less than a 10 it's a 10 it's a 10 such
a small amount of money up down and then
920 running like clockwork lovely
relationship with the landlord there's
just there's just no issues I would I
would probably take this on myself and I
don't even do rent events anymore but
love it and you know what as well Stella
because she's such a warm beautiful
caring person I feel like that's what
their kind of tenants that she attracts
are that's the kind of landlords that
she attracts and it really goes to show
that it's not just about knowledge it's
about action and spent just about noise
and action it's also about being a kind
person because you definitely attract
what you are so loved spending time with
Stella she's amazing
love it
very attractive much more attractive
than the last house but you know what
ultimately it doesn't really matter that
much to me how attractive a house is on
the outside it's more about it's more
about the inside and how much money it's
making and that kind of stuff it's all
about the numbers very big who's
responsible for cut in the garden you
personally do it right sorry that I okay
I just I just admit right then I just
saw you picturing the gun how much does
that cost okay jeez I need to
renegotiate with my gardeners so Wendy
and this only just became vacant
Dannette on the weekend do you normally
before you do viewings do you put
bedding on or what how does that work
when you show them around the tenants do
you sell to them because you see when I
show parents around I sell to them yeah
like if I was shown and tenant man in
this room right now I just say things
like yeah it's really quiet as you can
hear yet still really close to the
center
you know what was it what was it that
made you want to look around this room
and then I'll hear what they like and
then I'll play on it and then I'll say
things like you know I know it's not
that there's bedding is not on right now
but if you can picture what it would
look like when there's some pictures and
some and I'll step back and I'll just
let you know I really sell and then at
the end I'll say I think the end I'll
say you know so what are you thinking
and that's like a pre pre closed I'm
thinking it sounds good okay so you know
I mean well assuming that you was take
this one when would you be looking to
move in chiana's quite soon probably
next week okay well I could get the
paperwork sent out to you and I'll just
I'll just close them I
it's good good proper license take Jim
our thermostat set for 19 degrees to be
fair they're all very clean very nice
and I can't I honestly can't believe how
quiet is considering how closely I guess
I'll just it's quite a quiet place
anyway
great house you know what it's funny
about about these properties is that
there's it's thoughtless like normally
even if you went in my houses there'd be
something I could fight if I was trying
to be picky maybe the the battery in the
fire alarm would be gone and you just be
here they bit you know something or the
beer tenant leaves to find a bit messy
or there'd be some problem but these
it's just faultless so I feel again and
the return on investment as well that's
the thing she's putting down like a
small amount of money just up for it
deposit up from rent and making a grand
a month profit a grand a month profit on
one deal and it's smooth and the tenants
lover and the landlord's happy how could
I give it less than a ten I just I'd be
a jerk to give it less than ten ten well
I'm very interested in hearing what she
she's right in these because again I
can't say that she would even give it
less than a ten I would make this one an
eight as I've managed to get a landlord
to put in order furniture I've got a
good lease term on this property and
also because the languor was able to put
in order furniture and the profits
everyone feels really good I think Sam
would probably race it online due to how
much profit is making the type of
tenants that are in this property and
the size of the rooms
ten ten ten ten ten ten I hope the last
house has got something wrong with it so
I can downgrade it hi sorry I'm Stella
great to meet you Stella doing a great
job good you bet you're happy with yeah
so any seller came along good good offer
and she took the house on and brilliant
that's fantastic that's great well Louis
to meet you thank you so much yeah yeah
well she's always did a good job yeah
when I first started in property I had
so many people coming up to me all no
this is a scam it's not gonna work oh
never heard of that it must it's
definitely not going to work as a scam
so much negativity around me but I mean
it's bound to happen what you've got to
do is keep the motivation within
yourself you know it's not a scam I've
had to keep that in my head that I know
is not a scam I know it could work and
I'm going to show people that I can work
so I had to keep him pushed I kept on
pushing myself to make sure that I made
the most of the opportunities that I had
around me and to show people don't no
it's not a scam and it does work and
I'll show you how it works and I've
shown people that works I believe having
the support of family and friends around
is extremely important I went onto the
crash call with my mom brother and
sister we all did it together
I think it's extremely important to have
those who you're around the most support
you in your journey even if they don't
support you on your journey find people
that you can be around who will support
you and who will be there to help you
whenever you need to it's really
important to have that strong community
spirit around you people that will
continue to help you excel which is
definitely something that you have only
academy everybody today is for the same
reason everybody wants to see everybody
succeed so the Academy is a perfect
environment to be in to get you that
motivation to keep you on that ball to
keep you motivated and to keep you on
that lighter success so if you just
journey there have been times where I
felt like I don't wanna do this anymore
I want to give up just because it is
hard I mean like I said before you do
get many many
many knows and it's having that self
motivation and the right people around
you to keep you going
my mom's a very strong point for this
she keeps me going she makes sure that
I'm always always committed to this
journey path and I'm seeing it through
she's pushing me into the right areas to
make sure that I constantly move forward
and I'm progressing my property journey
so self motivation Plus having bright
people around you keeps you going cuz
there definitely will be times where
you'll feel like giving up especially
when you're looking for your first went
to rent deal it can be hard but you just
got to keep on going my relationship
with my mom is amazing I am she's my
walk she's been there for me since well
forever really in waivered that I needed
to do she's always supported me she's
been holding hand from me on this
journey it's because of my mum died when
in the crash course I probably wouldn't
or definitely wouldn't be had mother for
my mum pushing me to strive on this
journey and making sure that I succeed
she's definitely been my backbone in
this journey and pushing me forward to
do I need to do my mom wanted me to go
into the crash because she saw something
in Sandra leads to be honest I'd never
heard of Samuel before the crash course
but my mum had and she was raving about
Samuel she went on a crash course I
think about two weeks before I went on
it and she came back a raving about it
and it was amazing experience
she loved Samuel she loved all he was
about she loved what he could offer and
she just told me you need to book it
need to go one to it so I booked it I
went on it myself and yeah it was I
could definitely see what she was
talking about it was an amazing
experience
so if you've got visitors did you get
this pot was really there right so these
a lot of these are already existing HMOs
on tonight with landlords that are like
I've done this now I don't want the
house off yeah that makes sense
one of the things I notice about all
your properties is they're all but nice
kitchens the kitchens are big nice I
think that's probably important yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah
and no one's room smells yeah they're
all nice a little bit messy but clean
that you've got some really good tenants
how much did these guys pay eight
seventy five and this all fall in this
house yeah I guess they all are bought
from that one room in that one house
they're all full what the tenants like
here so with this property then it's a
different landlord what did you have to
pay up front one month deposit no
furniture so you didn't have to buy
furniture you didn't have to pay for any
refurb so and how much you painted over
3300 so you paid what six six yeah and
the deposit okay so about seven grand
she paid about seven grand but you're
making a grand no you're making nine
hundred a month so that'll be paid back
after what well maybe nine months yeah
and then it's just profit then he's that
the case of all your properties that's
good
love it fantastic what can I say she put
down one month's deposit one month
that's a total of 7,000 pound she's not
playing any maintenance there's no
refurb there was no furniture to have to
pay for it was all included and she's
making a 900-pound profit a month not
hoping to make its all full nine hundred
pounds coming in so the return on
investment on that and we work that out
so the profits ten thousand eight
hundred a year divided by seven thousand
so it is a one hundred and fifty four
percent return on investment tenants are
happy house is clean ten out of ten from
me I was hoping I'd find something wrong
with it I wanted to come out and give
give Stella some you know some tips or
said oh you could do this but he can do
that I think the only thing that Stella
could do better is she because she lives
in London she's getting a current
against a one-in-four clothes right so
it she has to show for tenants around to
get someone in but and that's for people
that actually qualify that she wants to
move in so maybe she could work on that
and cut down the travel cost a little
bit by getting Barrett sales but
[Music]
so we viewed all four houses in Oxford
to be honest I'm gonna reserve judgment
no they're all good we're gonna go
inside we're gonna find a quiet spot and
then me instead we're going to have a
conversation I'm going to tell her
exactly how I rated each property and
also generally overall how I think she's
done with these properties in Oxford
let's go great day excellent day overall
I'm impressed I've got to say it can't
be can't be live so great job the first
property you said that the first
property was like your favorite because
it was like your baby yes my first paper
meant to rent property yeah the joy of
getting that I can remember when I first
opened the doors had the keys and sign
the contract was like wow yeah I finally
started even the figures that's making
you the most profit isn't it it is yeah
you only marked that seven yeah you
thought I would say would you get out of
ten I gave it I think I gave it an eight
yeah you know I gave it our turn what
what do you reckon
why you already said yeah oh I gave it a
10 willing no I gave it a 10 really
because it's a great house there was
nothing wrong with it you did put down
quite a bit of money but you got a loan
to do it and the money that you put down
isn't lost
it was just not from rent yeah you
didn't have to pay anything else for
three months so actually I thought about
it and I thought to mark it less than a
10 would be would be criminal I wasn't
expecting that and then other three
properties yeah
I'm not being funny but I might every
single one attend was not expecting that
oh oh oh why even wasted it highly for
you for you so yeah I reckon Amala chair
because honestly I mean when when you go
around properties normally investment
properties you can they're like the
batteries aren't changed there's some
issues there's mess there's a really
smelly bear there's a problem with one
of the tenants your properties are in
great condition
great repair that
tenants are happy that all fall apart
from one room which is gonna get filled
really really soon yeah everyone was
raving about you you you built it with
no money how could I mark any of those
properties less than their tent I just
couldn't well thank you I really
appreciate their yeah but even more
importantly that is I'm not user ten
yeah yes in terms of my tenant
management no in terms of just use a
person and you as a business person
because you are you just have it you've
got it and I want to have been so
impressed because when people come on
Wednesday every week I feel like I'm
gonna start doing this more yeah
sometimes I hear the fingers hear the
stories I know it's true but actually
seeing each property meeting the tenants
meeting the landlords I'm just I'm
really really really yeah Frank you've
massive respect when I first started I
saw it as a side hustle but now I'm
seeing it more as a business so my
learning curve is that is to put
yourself out there go out there talk to
agents and I try to do it from you know
just from what abused us and then emails
here and there but you really have to be
out there to really get those good deals
to make that difference so it's just
putting yourself out there going for
what you won and just struggle for that
yes and still shock to this day that
I've come this far
like it's amazing to see where I started
out with the first meant to rent door
and even the process of getting that
first meant to mint dill to having 4-h
and momentum it builds it's just this
fantastic it's a great feeling to know
that you've built that portfolio up and
you're succeeding at it it's amazing
it's at the moment with all the duels
that I haven't making roughly about four
thousand three hundred a month in profit
and I can gladly say that I am
financially free when I got my first yes
to have a mental mental I felt relieved
it was like a weight off your shoulders
and having so many knows continuously
going into estate agent shops and here
no-no-no to get that yes it was just
okay great I've gotten over that barrier
now let's see if everything else can
work and just making sure that you keep
that good relationship with the estate
agents so that once they say yes they're
gonna follow through and you're gonna
get that deal I do not believe that I
would be where I am now if I had not
gone on a crash course there's so many
elements to the crash to the crash
course and the Academy that I would not
have today we have Samuel and the team's
hope I've managed to build my confidence
I've managed to see property as a
business I've managed to put myself in
situations I usually wouldn't to grow my
business to grow my portfolio to
understand property better and this is
definitely something that I would not
have got if I didn't join a crash course
I spent a lot of money signing up on
City Academy and basically everything I
had just so I could have the opportunity
to be in that room and I can 100% say
it's worth it it really is a good
investment it's a lifetime investment
you think about it because the skills
you learn on the academy are skills that
we would use for many many many years to
come so many people in the Academy room
doing deals making it out there
different projects different JV
partnerships as well I mean it's not
just Sandra Lee's team that you're
learning from mister people in the room
they have so much knowledge to share
people from different backgrounds people
with different experiences there's so
much information in that room so much
experience so much energy definitely I
mean we want to be in my advice to
somebody who wants to start getting
involved in property is booked on the
crash course take that step I know
sometimes it's hard and we have all
these commitments outside and you know
always thinking are maybe next year
maybe next month but honestly start now
even if it's just little steps that
you're doing right now just take those
little steps because you never know
where that can take you and honestly
this is the time now to start getting
involved in properties we all have
excuses we all have other commitments
but just taking that small time to get
involved just join going on a crash
course take that opportunity I'm telling
you know you won't be disappointed ah so
been it's been a really fun day
I always liked Stella I always rated a
very very highly when I first met her
believe it or not she was I didn't even
see her she was so reserved she was sat
in the back of the crash course and she
was really shy but what she's built up
is absolutely incredible and then now
she's looking to do development deals
and the experience that she's got from
the rent to rents dealing with tenants
dealing with landlords and agents the
experience along with the cash flow
that's now enabled her if she wanted to
she could quit work at the time that
she's got she's going to blow up you
watch this space and I'll tell you
something if she starts doing big
development deals I'm going to be a
joint venture partner because I want to
work with more people like Stella no
Stella great job
in the good thinking that I won't react
you whisper in my man thinking I will be
the same to conviction in a fact
[Music]